Je vous lis à nouveau juste la première section,
donc les premiers paragraphes du chapitre 6
de notre confession des foires,
le chapitre qui traite de la chute de l'homme,
les péchés et son châtiment.
Quand on fera un abordage doctrinaire
de ces chapitres,
on va organiser les conclusions auxquelles
on arrive par une considération
de l'exposition biblique directe.
Le premier grand exercice qu'on est en train de faire,
c'est d'aller directement vers la Bible
sur les textes principaux qui traitent
de la chute du péché et du châtiment,
notamment les chapitres 3 de Genèse,
pour qu'après, lorsqu'on reviendra
à ces paragraphes de la confession des foires,
on ait plus la capacité d'identifier
de quoi il parle.
Et aujourd'hui, on va juste introduire cette leçon
avec la lecture du premier paragraphe
qui parle plus directement,
notamment de la chute.
Et donc, le paragraphe 1 nous dit,
« Bien qu'il ait créé l'homme droit et parfait
et lui a donné une loi juste
qui était en vue de la vie
s'il l'avait observée
et qui l'ait menacée des morts
s'il la transgressait.
L'homme n'a pas gardé longtemps cet honneur.
Utilisant subtilement les serpents,
Satan séduisit Ève
et par elle, il séduisit Adam
qui, sans contente sur lui,
transgressa volontairement la loi de leur création
et les commandements qui leur avaient été donnés
en mangeant du fruit défendu.
Il a plu à Dieu
de permettre cette chute
dans son conseil sage et saint
puisqu'il avait déterminé
de l'utiliser pour manifester sa gloire. »
Donc, c'est un paragraphe très bien rédigé.
Et si on se demande
d'où sont sorties ces déclarations,
on fait cet exercice
des considérations bibliques.
Donc, ce qu'on a déjà abordé
quand on s'approche du thème
de la chute.
La première chose,
c'était un rappel de l'importance de l'ordre.
Donc, on a d'abord établi les bases
sur les Écritures,
la seule base fiable des connaissances de Dieu.
Et ensuite, on a considéré
les plus importants,
qui Dieu est,
concentré sur cet objectif
qui est l'objectif primaire de la Bible.
Nous présenter qui Dieu est
et comment nous pouvons nous réconcilier avec lui.
Donc, les attributs de Dieu,
ses qualités,
ses perfections,
c'est très important d'avoir considéré ça
avant de considérer la chute.
Car comme j'évoquais dans ma prière,
nous sommes déjà tachés
par la corruption du péché
de cet épisode de la chute.
Et nous avons déjà une tendance
qui est aussi une caractéristique,
comme on verra,
immédiate après la chute,
d'une tendance à se victimiser,
à mettre Dieu en question.
On a une tendance très facile
à oublier
quel était l'état merveilleux
dans lequel Dieu nous a créés.
On a la tendance d'oublier
notre responsabilité
les moments où on a choisi de pécher.
Mais en même temps,
on commence à mettre
en question si Dieu est bon,
sans parfait envers l'humanité,
pourquoi il a même permis
qu'on ait la possibilité
de tomber.
Et donc,
quand on est déjà un clan
dans cette direction,
c'est important de revenir
à la base.
Et voilà pourquoi,
avant de présenter
la chute de l'homme,
on a considéré
toutes ces autres doctrines
dans les bons ordres.
avant de permettre
que nos pensées
ou nos lèvres
osent mettre en question
la sainteté de Dieu,
nous devons revenir
aux passages bibliques
qui sont beaucoup plus nombreux,
beaucoup plus explicites
pour nous suggérer
ou pour nous convaincre
de la sainteté de Dieu,
de la bonté de Dieu,
des bonnes intentions de Dieu
envers l'humanité.
Voilà pourquoi
l'ordre dans la théologie
est important,
même dans un niveau
spirituel,
dans un niveau
de nos crises personnelles.
Mais c'est très important
sur cet ordre
à cause de l'interaction
et la logique
de ces doctrines.
Donc,
si je n'ai pas
une bonne compréhension
de qui Dieu est,
je n'aurai pas
la compréhension
de comment Dieu
m'a créé à son image.
Si je ne comprends pas
les privilèges
et les responsabilités
que j'avais
en tant qu'image
de Dieu dans la création,
je ne comprends pas
la chute.
Si je ne comprends pas
la chute selon la Bible,
je ne comprends pas
la rédemption,
l'évangile.
Et je ne comprends même pas
comment j'ai fonctionné
aujourd'hui,
comment surmonter
mes crises,
comment réagir
à ces restes
de péché,
même après ma conversion,
qui rendent ma vie
une bataille,
que mon interaction
avec ce monde
soit si difficile
que je sois marqué
par des crises
internes ou externes.
Et donc,
voilà l'importance
de l'ordre.
Ensuite,
on a parlé
de la pertinence
particulière
de cette doctrine.
Elle est
une doctrine,
selon Jonathan Edwards,
qui n'a pas besoin
de beaucoup
de défenses
apologétiques,
c'est-à-dire
on n'a pas besoin
de convaincre
les personnes
qu'il y a quelque chose
de mauvais
avec l'humanité
et l'histoire
de l'humanité.
Les pages
de l'humanité
sont tachées de sang
et nos vies
personnelles
sont marquées
par des crises,
par des syndromes
d'hépanie,
par des coupabilités,
par une insatisfaction
vis-à-vis
à nos propres attentes
par rapport
à comment
on devrait marcher
et des crises
profondes
des volontés,
prise d'identité,
dans tous les sens.
Donc,
la race humaine
en elle-même
est déjà
la preuve
que l'être humain
est marqué
par des aspirations
qui sont
beaucoup plus élevées
que la réalité
dont ils arrivent
à vivre.
L'aspiration
d'être infini
lorsque nous sommes
infinis et vulnérables.
L'aspiration
d'être moralement
parfait
ou au moins mieux
lorsque nous n'arrivons
pas à vivre
à la hauteur
de nos propres
consciences.
Très prêtes
à juger les autres
mais en même temps
on n'arrive pas
à nous laisser juger
par nos propres critères.
Et donc,
on a considéré
l'aspect universel
et explicite
du fait
que la chute
a eu lieu.
Que l'être humain
est en dissonance.
Que en même temps
qu'il est noble,
voilà la manière
dont Blaise Pascal
a décrit
cette crise,
la crise suprême
selon lui,
c'est que l'homme
soit si élevé
dans sa noblesse
et en même temps
si misérable
dans sa condition.
Et donc,
c'est aussi pertinent
non seulement
pour qu'on puisse
comprendre
ce qui se passe
avec l'humanité
mais c'est pertinent aussi
car c'est un événement
fondamental
pour la compréhension
de l'homme
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui,
la compréhension
de l'histoire
telle qu'elle se déroule,
la compréhension
de la nature
ou notre rapport
envers la nature
dans sa condition
de corruption
à cause
de notre péché,
les frustrations
des essais
d'amélioration
pour l'être humain,
on n'a pas
la compréhension
de ce qu'est l'évangile
ni la sanctification
si on n'a pas
la compréhension
de cette chute.
Et là,
on a considéré aussi
quels sont
les diagnostics humains
car personne n'aimit
les problèmes
mais on essaie
d'expliquer
ces problèmes.
Donc pour certains,
ces problèmes,
c'est un problème
inhérent à la race humaine,
c'est-à-dire
des aspirations
plus élevées,
la noblesse
de l'homme
et le fait
qu'il soit cruel
et misérable.
Et donc il y a
cette notion
de dualisme
comme si
la réalité ultime
ou l'origine
de toutes les choses
soit déjà dualiste,
des forces opposées
pour les biens
et pour les mals
et l'homme
est tout simplement
marqué par ces choses.
L'anthropologie
séculière,
qu'elles viennent
de la sociologie,
de la psychanalyse,
etc.,
elles sont toutes marquées
par une perspective
humaniste
sous l'influence
de la théorie
de l'évolution.
Et de manière générale,
ces crises de l'homme,
ces incapacités
de vivre
en conformité
avec leurs demandes
plus élevées
s'expliquent
par le fait
que déjà,
il n'y a même
pas de sens
en fait
pour avoir
des aspirations
plus élevées,
des significations.
Car si nous sommes
les fruits
d'une explosion,
d'une énergie
qui ne dépense pas,
qui n'a pas
de sentiments,
on n'arrive pas
à expliquer
la personnalité
de l'homme,
les sentiments
l'amour,
l'envie
d'avoir une signification
en but d'existence.
Et quand on est
encore plus
dedans
l'influence
évolutionniste,
on va suggérer
tout simplement
qui est dans
cette complexité
de notre évolution,
on a encore
les restes
de ces instants
ou forces
bestiales
ou animales
qui sont là.
Donc c'est
une évolution.
Pour d'autres théories,
c'est tout simplement
ils veulent nier
la question
ou la discussion
des moralités
et ils veulent
tout simplement
présenter
ces défis,
la difficulté
que nos volontés
soient accomplies
ou qu'on aboutisse
à une plus grande
noblesse
soient expliquées
tout simplement
car l'origine,
soit Dieu
ou n'importe quelle
origine,
a inséré
en nous
ces résistances
pour qu'on puisse
s'exercer
envers la vertu.
Et ils utilisent
un langage
qui n'est pas
dans la direction
de n'émoraliser,
de dire
cela est mauvais,
c'est un péché,
mais c'est plutôt
absence
des qualités.
Et c'est là,
à partir de là
vous allez comprendre
pourquoi c'est important
d'identifier
dans la société
ces catégories
car non seulement
les diagnostics,
c'est celui
que je viens
de vous présenter,
mais ce qui a été
très popularisé
n'est pas seulement
cette perspective
par rapport
à l'être humain,
mais c'est aussi
les traitements
qui vont tous
dans la même direction.
Donc un des traitements
c'est de proposer
l'existentialisme
athée.
Il n'y a pas
des corrects
ou tort,
ce qui est
est correct,
tout simplement
est,
et nous devons avoir
une attitude
de conformité
ou une attitude
très positiviste
envers les réalités
qui sont là.
La psychanalyse
aura une tendance
à travailler
pour être d'accord
avec nos volontés
et chercher
à supprimer
les sentiments
des coupabilités.
Il y aura
beaucoup
qui vont mettre
l'emphase
sur cet aspect
d'absence
de qualité
ou d'opportunité
et qui vont
développer
un espèce
de traitement
positiviste
où on ne peut
jamais confronter
les personnes
et à chaque fois
l'explication
c'est pour dire
c'est l'amour
qui l'a manqué
peut-être
à son enfance,
c'est plus
d'affirmation
qu'il a manqué,
mais on a enlevé
de nos sociétés
même dans les vocabulaires
comme je vous ai déjà dit
au lieu de dire
c'est incorrect
c'est un péché
on cherche
à diagnostiquer
tout
comme si c'était
une maladie.
Si
je justifie
mes fautes
car je suis bipolaire
ce n'est pas pour dire
qu'un tel cadre
diagnostique
puisse
n'existe absolument pas
mais en réalité
nous sommes très vite
dans notre génération
à embrasser
ces diagnostics
car les péchés
chez nous
aiment bien
ne pas se voir
qu'en coupable
mais embrasser
la conception
des maladies
bipolaires
quand on est
des mauvaises humeurs
quand on ne veut pas
maîtriser
ce que la Bible appelle
les accès de colère
les péchés
quand on ne veut pas
se responsabiliser
par ces choses
c'est beaucoup plus facile
de médire
et dire aux autres
je suis bipolaire
je suis schizophrénique
car on est
dans la dynamique
de la victimisation
et pas dans la dynamique
de la responsabilisation
et la responsabilisation
et si on n'arrive pas
à traiter les problèmes
par sa racine
on n'arrive pas
à traiter les problèmes
car même si
j'embrasse
des diagnostics
humains
ma conscience
qui a été faite
par Dieu
ne sera jamais
satisfaite
avec ses excuses
elle ne sera jamais
apaisée
on pense
à l'influence
de nos parents
c'est mon éducation
c'est mon sang italien
c'est ma culture
mais nous voulons
à chaque fois
faire comme Adam
a fait
ou comme Ève
c'est les serpents
Ève a dit
et Adam a dit
c'est la femme
qui tu m'as donnée
en cherchant
à coupabiliser Dieu
même nos enfants
sont en train
de souffrir
à cause de la paresse
de plusieurs parents
on n'a jamais eu
une génération
qui a été
si tant diagnostiquée
avec
des troubles
de comportement
qui avaient été
traités tout simplement
comme différence
des tempéraments
et à nouveau
c'est pas pour dire
qu'il n'y a pas
en fait
quelques diagnostics
qui devraient être
considérés
comme véritablement
la réalité
mais nous sommes
très vite
à accepter
la proposition
à donner
des médicaments
aux enfants
parce que
tout ce qui
il pourrait
dépendre
c'était un peu plus
de notre temps
un peu plus
de notre patience
de notre discipline
pour mieux gérer
les différences
des comportements
entre eux
et malheureusement
cette industrie
qui s'est rétro
nourrie
s'est rétro
alimente
elle a même
qui fait
les diagnostics
et qui gagne
l'argent
avec les médicaments
et donc
c'est la réalité
de ce qui nous sommes
et tous ces traitements
n'arrivent jamais
à régler les problèmes
de l'homme
ce n'est pas
plus d'instructions
plus de civilité
plus de médicaments
plus de divertissement
plus d'affirmation
les problèmes
sont beaucoup plus
radicals
et les traitements
sont beaucoup plus
radicals
et voilà pourquoi
nous avons absolument
besoin de considérer
la nécessité
absolue
de la révélation
biblique
pour qu'on arrive
en diagnostic
de l'être humain
qui nous présente
la réelle cause
de tous ces symptômes
et qui nous présente
aussi
la vraie guérison
donc la révélation
biblique
elle nous présente
l'opposé
de toutes ces théories
dans le sens
où ces théories
se développent
soit dans l'existence
éternelle
des deux forces égales
qui s'opposent
bien et mal
et selon
les récits bibliques
il y a une seule force
éternelle
qui prédomine
et qui sera victorieuse
rien que l'effet
qu'on soit encore vivant
sous la patience
des dieux
c'est car
il a retardé
la punition ultime
et l'extirpation
de tous les maux
pour nous donner
l'opportunité
de nous réconcilier
avec lui
mais un jour
tous les maux
seront extirpés
et donc
il n'y a pas
une cohabitation
éternelle
entre mal et bien
le récit biblique
ne va pas non plus
dans la direction
d'une évolution
pour l'homme
c'est les total opposés
l'homme est créé
dans son sommet
et on évoque
l'involution
de l'homme
ou la dévolution
je ne sais pas
quels sont les termes
en français
que vous utilisez
régression
en tout cas
la révélation biblique
est une révélation
et voilà pourquoi
on a insisté
sur cette importance
qui nous présente
la chute
comme un élément
nécessaire
pour complémenter
cette anthropologie
que nous avons considéré
dès l'homme
lorsqu'il a été créé
parfait
à l'image des dieux
quel est
le plus grand problème
avec toutes les théories
humaines
c'est car
elles essayent
d'observer l'homme
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
et ils croient
que ce qu'ils observent
aujourd'hui
à propos de l'homme
a été la vérité
pour toujours
donc ils ne considèrent
par la discontinuité
dans la race humaine
et cette crise
et cette dissonance
entre désir
d'être infini
en étant vulnérable
et fini
fragile
ces désirs
des grandeurs
lorsqu'on voit
notre misère
ces désirs
d'une moralité parfaite
d'une société parfaite
lorsqu'on vit
de cette manière
tragique
dont on vit
on est devant
des aspirations
justifiables
dans la création
car on a été créé
pour ça
mais en même temps
c'est qu'il a chute
qui peut nous expliquer
pourquoi on n'a pas
la puissance
de vivre à la hauteur
de ces choses
donc la révélation
biblique
est un récit
inspiré
par les Saint-Esprit
les seuls
historiciens
qui étaient présents
à la création
et à la chute
car il a observé
comme témoin
de toutes ces choses
il a inspiré
Moïse
pour
registrer
ces récits
qui doit être
traité
comme histoire
pour nous
histoire
littérale
on a
considéré
les évidences
bibliques
et même historiques
pour lesquelles
on doit considérer
Genèse 3
comme littérale
et c'était très important
de les faire
et il faut qu'on insiste
que Genèse 3
elle est fondément
historique
pour comprendre
l'humanité
elle est fondément
biblique
car toute la Bible
va se dérouler
pour montrer
des Genèse 4
des Genèse 3
même
jusqu'à la fin
de l'Apocalypse
nous sommes devant
la réponse
gracieuse
des dieux
à ces faits
historiques
et on a vu
plusieurs passages
qui montrent
les rapports directs
entre Genèse 3
et plusieurs
manières
dont plusieurs
rédacteurs
de la Bible
d'autres portions
vont citer
l'épisode de Genèse
comme littéral
ce qu'on a fait
ensuite
voilà
c'est
de présenter
quels seront
les parcours
donc
Genèse
c'est histoire littérale
et ensuite
ce qu'on a fait
la dernière semaine
c'était la considération
de l'état
original
de l'homme
et pourquoi
c'est important
car quand on a considéré
l'homme
étant créé
comme l'image
des dieux
on était plus concentré
à voir
sa gloire
dans la création
mais il y a
certaines portions
auxquelles on doit revenir
pour mieux comprendre
ce qui a été
les tests
de l'homme
et ce qui a été
la chute
dans l'état
original
donc l'environnement
et la condition
de l'homme
elle est
très importante
pour la considération
de la chute
pour qu'on n'ait pas
cette tendance
à mettre Dieu
en question
quand on voit
la manière
dont la chute
s'est déroulée
et donc
les pactes
que Dieu a établis
avec Adam
c'était plutôt
une manifestation
ou une mesure
des grâces
donc si vous voulez
revenir
à certains passages
des Genès 1 et 2
juste pour faire
ce rappel
l'état
des béatitudes
humaines
il est très
généreusement décrit
à partir du moment
où l'homme est créé
il est créé
en Genèse 1
verset 26 à 31
pardon
oui c'est ça
verset 26 à 31
qui nous dit
les déroulés
du sixième jour
et qui nous montre
de manière très glorieuse
que l'homme a été créé
comme les sommets
de la création
à l'image des dieux
hommes et femmes
ont été créés
et ils ont reçu
cette
mission parfaite
de représenter
Dieu
pour ces mondes
dans cette interaction
il a été élevé
de la poussière
qui était la terre
dans la terre
il a été élevé
à la position
d'image des dieux
et donc
il avait
à sa disposition
toute la richesse
de cet univers
et
il devrait
gouverner
cet univers
à l'image des dieux
en amenant
cette perfection
je vais revenir
garder ces mots
cette perfection
séminale
initiale
qui devrait encore
être de plus en plus
développer
car l'homme
allait fonctionner
dans ces mondes
comme
en représentant
des dieux
pour toute la création
d'entre tous
les aspects
d'entre tous les aspects
de cette perfection
initiale
de cette félicité
de cette béatitude
initiale
il était parfait
en signification
parfait en être
parfait dans ses relations
avec lui-même
et sa conscience
avec Dieu
avec son épouse
donc la famille
et avec les mondes
qui étaient
à service
de l'homme
de manière généreuse
pour les biens
donc là
c'est un résumé
général
que Genèse nous donne
depuis
la première mention
qui est vraiment
très concise
et à partir du chapitre 2
nous avons
une description
du déroulé
de cette manière
dont Dieu
a créé l'homme
et là
il va citer
la félicité
suprême
déjà
en Genèse 2
verset 2
donc une fois
que Dieu
va achever
le septième jour
son œuvre
il va se reposer
c'est-à-dire
c'est une contemplation
pour prendre
de la joie
il va sanctifier
ses jours
et donc l'homme
va interagir
avec la création
toute la création
avec son épouse
etc
va travailler
va accomplir
sa mission
avec l'aide
de son épouse
et un jour
sur sept
il va revenir
devant Dieu
pour réjouir
d'une communion
intense avec Dieu
même si dans la virée
de tous les jours
il y avait déjà
de la communion
avec Dieu
il y avait un jour
généreux d'intimité
et là c'était
les moments
suprêmes
de la béatitude
car l'homme
ayant accompli
pendant six jours
son but
dans son interaction
avec la création
pourrait venir
remplir des joies
pour rendre
cette rédivabilité
très positive
devant Dieu
surpris
et émerveillé
avec toutes les choses
qu'il a pu construire
toutes les choses
qu'il a pu réjouir
avec son épouse
et donc
venir pour adorer
Dieu
le septième jour
pour contempler
ce qu'il était
en train de faire
en représentant Dieu
dans la création
en réjouissant
de cette intimité
glorieuse avec Dieu
donc l'une de nos
plus grandes crises
encore aujourd'hui
c'est que quand on va
au culte
on va conscient
de beaucoup de manquements
pendant la semaine
et nous avons
cette aspiration
pour les jours
où
tout sera rendu parfait
mais en même temps
on réjouit déjà
d'une félicité
très élevée
car l'Écrit
s'est déjà accompli
à notre place
c'est qu'on n'arrive
plus à accomplir
on n'est pas
comme Israël
avant Christ
mais on n'est pas
non plus
comme Adam
avant la chute
et donc
au sommet
de cette félicité
c'était cette communion
avec Dieu
avec la sensation
d'avoir accompli
parfaitement
les buts
de notre création
en ayant glorifié Dieu
pendant toute la semaine
maintenant
je vais me glorifier
en Dieu
ok
et ça c'est
la structure
qui va être préservée
pour toujours
donc ensuite
il y a
des descriptions
plus détaillées
de l'environnement
comme par exemple
la description
qui nous est faite
du verset 10
au verset 14
qui va évoquer
les rivières
les pays
et les pierres
donc un réalisme
historique
et je vous rappelle
Dieu avait créé
l'homme
en dehors
de ses jardins
et a donné
l'homme
la mission
de représenter
Dieu
dans cette création
il devrait
développer la terre
cultiver la terre
multiplier
mais selon
quels paramètres
selon les paramètres
de l'église
du sanctuaire
et c'est quoi
les sanctuaires
à l'édan
c'est un jardin
que Dieu lui-même
avait
développé
c'est Dieu lui-même
qui donne les modèles
les paramètres
les standards
pour qu'Adam
et Ève
dans cette communion
avec Dieu
dans ces lieux
particuliers
spécial
puissent
et voilà pourquoi
les textes nous disent
ces fleuves
partaient
de l'édan
et s'est distribuée
envers toutes les nations
donc c'est une représentation
du chirement
que l'humanité
devrait prendre
pour se multiplier
selon les paramètres
du jardin
et développer
les bénédictions
des dieux généreuses
envers toute la terre
et la même chose
est représentée
par ces pays
qui sont mentionnés
des pays
qui sont marqués
par beaucoup
des richesses
donc voilà
les contextes
dans lesquels
on a été créé
la Bible est généreuse
pour décrire
tous les fruits
qui Dieu
nous a donnés
dans ce sens là
il y a deux points
qui sont très importants
à remarquer
au moins
deux petits passages
qu'il faut qu'on revienne
au chapitre 2
car c'est la base
de la compréhension
de la chute
verset 7
l'éternel Dieu
forma l'homme
de la poussière
de la terre
il souffla
dans ses narines
un souffle de vie
et l'homme
devient un être vivant
donc remarquez bien
c'est que nous sommes
poussière
en qui
les saints esprits
a été soufflé
l'esprit des dieux
dans cette poussière
pour faire de nous
des âmes vivantes
habitation des dieux
quelque chose
qui est
infiniment plus élevé
que la réalité
de n'importe quelle
autre créature
qui nous entoure
puis l'éternel Dieu
planta les jardins
dans les dents
du côté de l'Orient
et il mit l'homme
qui l'avait formé
l'éternel
fit pousser du sol
des arbres
et de toutes espèces
agréable
à voir
et bon à manger
attention
on sait
que dans la tentation
dans la perspective
d'Eve
le moment
elle va shooter
elle va regarder
par cette même
voix
bon à manger
ou plutôt
apparemment
agréable
à manger
et agréable
à la vue
mais c'est très important
de remarquer ici
que Dieu avait
fait pousser
du sol
des arbres
de toutes espèces
et elles étaient
toutes agréables
à voir
et bon à manger
pourquoi c'est important
d'être bien
attentif ici
car
il n'y a aucun
indice
d'une prédisposition
des dieux
envers la restriction
pour les êtres humains
cette restriction
qui Dieu va établir
bientôt
n'a pas pour but
restreindre la réjouissance
des biens terrestres
c'est un autre but
on va comprendre
mais c'est très important
de remarquer déjà
qu'il n'y avait pas
une tentation
particulière
dans cet arbre
qui ne pourrait
pas être satisfait
ailleurs
partout
ok
en soi-même
bien sûr
en tant qu'arbre
en tant que
ce qui produit
les fruits
mais
il y avait aussi
l'arbre
de la vie
au milieu du jardin
et l'arbre
de la connaissance
du bien et du mal
et c'est à partir
de là
qu'on commence
à se demander
c'est quoi
ces arbres
l'arbre
de la vie
pour l'instant
le plus important
pour nous
c'est de remarquer
ce qu'on appelle
la félicité
séminale
qu'il y avait
Adam et Ève
dans son état
de perfection
ils étaient parfaits
parfaitement joyeux
mais en même temps
c'était comme la perfection
d'un sémence
une sémence parfaite
elle est déjà parfaite
en tant que sémence
mais elle peut encore
se développer
envers une plante
d'une plante
envers un arbre
et donc
la condition naturelle
dans laquelle
l'être humain
a été créé
c'était une condition
naturelle
de la vie
une connaissance
un degré
de Dieu
qui était plus
que suffisante
pour qu'il soit
dans la joie
et une impossibilité
même de tomber
dans un péché
car naturellement
étant créé
l'image des dieux
dans un monde
parfait
étant parfait
sans loi
externe
juste avec
la loi interne
on va dire
la loi
incentive
ou naturelle
l'être humain
par nature
dans un environnement
parfait
accomplissait
les buts
naturels
de son existence
c'est-à-dire
il reflétait
l'image
de Dieu
rien que par
l'accomplissement
naturel
de sa mission
il vivait
tout simplement
dans le monde
et il glorifiait
Dieu
tout simplement
dans le monde
par contre
il y avait
cet élément
qui reste mystérieux
pour nous
qui pourrait donner
à Adam
et Ève
ou l'humanité
la possibilité
de rendre
leur obéissance
naturelle
une obéissance
volontaire
une soumission
et une expression
de totale
confiance
au Dieu
créateur
à sa volonté
et à sa parole
donc c'est
pacte
qui est offert
c'est un pacte
des grâces
car c'était une possibilité
pour Adam
et Ève
d'élever
encore
leur position
envers Dieu
cette soumission
volontaire
qu'on peut
contempler
surtout dans les fils
surtout dans les plans
de la rédemption
qui est glorieuse
et Dieu
va établir
cette possibilité
ayant l'arbre
de la vie
comme représentation
de ce qui pourrait
consommer
l'approbation
dans ses tests
si l'homme
se soumet
volontairement
à Dieu
il est en train
de volontairement
vouloir sceller
cette relation
il approfondit
sa relation
avec Dieu
il rend sa relation
encore plus noble
mais il rend aussi
sa condition
plus élevée
car la condition
d'Adam
était parfaite
mais à partir
de ses pactes
elle était passible
des chutes
mais une fois
que la proposition
de l'arbre
de la vie
soit disponible
à partir
de l'approbation
dans l'obéissance
dans ce texte
nous voyons
que cet arbre
représente
les sceaux
de son approbation
donc si l'homme
était obéissant
pendant la période
que Dieu aurait déterminé
qu'on ne connait pas
combien de temps
ça serait
l'homme
allait manger
du fruit
de l'arbre
de la vie
et c'est tellement
historique
et tellement littéral
que Dieu a choisi
un arbre
pour être
cette représentation
que l'apocalypse
va nous montrer
les mêmes images
quand on arrivera
au paradis
et qu'est-ce que Dieu a fait
quand l'homme
a échoué
à manger de ses fruits
il les a
chassés du jardin
pour les empêcher
de manger
de l'arbre de la vie
c'est-à-dire
pour éviter
pour protéger
l'homme
de ne pas rendre
sa condition
des pécheurs
rébelles
éternelles
et donc
cet arbre
est présenté
en test
qui pourrait
élever
et les relations
de l'homme
ou la connaissance
des dieux
ou l'intimité
avec Dieu
de l'homme
et l'élevé
et l'élévation
de la condition
de l'homme
devenir
éternellement
parfait
sans la possibilité
des chutes
quand on saute
vers les versets
ces arbres
vont gagner
encore plus
d'explicité
donc c'est quoi
l'arbre de la connaissance
du bien et du mal
l'éternel
Dieu prit l'homme
et les plaça
dans les jardins
des dents
pour cultiver
et pour les garder
l'éternel
donne à cet ordre
à l'homme
tu pourras manger
de tous les arbres
du jardin
mais tu ne mangeras pas
de l'arbre de la connaissance
du bien et du mal
car les jours
où tu en mangeras
tu mourras
et donc à partir de là
il faut qu'on se demande
de manière plus claire
car ici c'est
l'établissement du pacte
c'est un pacte
dans quel sens
certains vont dire
c'est le pacte des œuvres
c'est plutôt un pacte
des grâces
encore à cause
des fêtes
que j'ai déjà démontrés
car ici
il y a une possibilité
d'élévation
il y a aussi
une protection
un ordre protectrice
ne mangez pas
de cet autre fruit
dans un contexte
de totale générosité
tu pourras manger
de tous les arbres
du jardin
mais tu ne mangeras pas
de l'arbre de la connaissance
du bien et du mal
pour que tu puisses
prouver pour toi-même
que ta soumission
à ma volonté
est volontaire
est plaisante
pour que tu puisses
prouver pour toi-même
c'est un peu l'attente
qu'on a à faire
envers nos enfants
qu'ils puissent comprendre
qu'ils ne sont pas
en train de suivre nos heures
tout simplement
car on veut leur bien
on veut imposer
les mécanes
ils sont convaincus
qu'il s'agit de leur bien
qu'il s'agit du mieux
pour eux
et c'est une manière
de manifester
leur amour
envers nous
tu pourras manger
de tous les arbres
mais tu ne mangeras pas
la connaissance
du bien et du mal
pourquoi connaissance
car les biens
étaient déjà connus
et la possibilité
de connaître
le mal
n'existait même pas
si ce n'était pas
ces tests
et ici
la connaissance
du bien et du mal
elle a deux connotations
la première
c'est la connaissance
expérimentale
du mal
car à partir du moment
où Dieu dit
si tu touches
à cet arbre
en mourant
tu vas mourir
car c'est la manière
dans l'original
de mettre l'emphase
sur cette réalité
certainement
tu vas mourir
sans aucun
ombre des doutes
tu vas mourir
en mourant
tu mourras
ok
Dieu n'a pas laissé
les moindres doutes
par rapport à ça
et donc
les mal
expérimental
deviendrait
une réalité
dans la race humaine
mais
les mal
en termes de conception
a été créé
ici aussi
car à partir du moment
où Dieu donne
une interdition
avec une menace
nous savons
que nous ne pouvons pas
aller dans sa direction
et voilà pourquoi
il a une deuxième connotation
car
en connaissant
que selon
les paramètres
des dieux
les biens
représentent
ne pas manger ses fruits
dans l'espoir
de manger l'arbre
de la vie
et les mal
représentent
manger ses fruits
si jamais
j'ose aller
dans sa direction
voilà la deuxième connotation
c'est les désirs
pour l'autonomie
c'est d'être
en désaccord
avec le fait
que Dieu
ait les droits
en tant que créateur
et en tant que juge
suprême
de déterminer
lui-même
ce qui est bon
et ce qui est mauvais
et tous les péchés
sont un acte
d'autonomie
de rébellion
les moindres péchés
représentent
d'agir contrairement
à ce que Dieu
a prescrit
pour nous
et ce que Dieu
a prescrit
pour nous
c'est toujours
le mieux pour nous
mais avant même
qu'on considère
ses conséquences
il est
les rois
les créateurs
absolus
et il a non seulement
les droits
mais même
une obligation morale
sur lui
d'extirper
les moindres
rebelles
et la moindre
rébellion
c'est une obligation morale
pour protéger
sa justice
pour que Dieu
soit Dieu
et ne peut pas
tolérer
la méchanceté
et donc
connaissance
du bien et du mal
c'est comme si
on voulait dire
c'est à moi
de déterminer
ce qui est bien
et ce qui est mal
qu'est-ce qu'on entend
parler aujourd'hui
relativisme
il n'y a pas
d'absolu moral
d'absolu
en termes
de vérité
c'est désir
d'être
autonome
donc voilà
les pactes
qui Dieu a établis
en vous rappelant
l'éternel
c'est à dire
les dieux
qui est
l'origine
de la vie
en qui tout
subsiste
vous êtes avec moi
l'éternel dieu
c'est à dire
les tout puissants
les seuls
véritables dieux
contre tous les idoles
donna cet ordre
c'était pas un conseil
c'était un ordre
et il a fait
envers
Adam
et je vous rappelle
il y a le nom
Isch
qui veut dire
homme
ou mal
Ischa
qui veut dire
femelle
ce sont des termes
utilisés dans la description
de la création
de la femme
par exemple
à partir de l'homme
mais quand la Bible
parle
à l'homme
et dans l'original
on trouve
Adam
c'est pour mettre
l'emphase
numéro 1
dans notre insignifiance
en termes
de l'origine terrestre
car Adam veut dire
terre
poussière
mais c'est aussi
la représentation
de toute l'humanité
et voilà pourquoi
c'est
concept
théologique
il est très important
car Adam
il était notre
représentant légal
il était les représentants
de toute la race
et il était
un représentant
parfait
c'est
Dieu lui-même
attention
si
cette moindre idée
passe par notre tête
je n'aurais pas aimé
qu'Adam soit
mon représentant
je ne l'ai pas choisi
heureusement
ce n'était pas
à nous de choisir
car
pour
plus parfaite
qui pourrait être
notre capacité
de choix
Dieu avait
une capacité
encore plus élevée
que la nôtre
donc c'est
Dieu lui-même
qui l'a choisi
et on sait très bien
que Dieu
n'allait jamais
choisir Adam
avec la moindre
connotation
d'injustice
ou d'impéfection
il était
pleinement
capable
et il était
placé
dans une condition
parfaite
et bien rien
qui manquait
dans les fonctionnements
de cet être humain
qui a été choisi
par Dieu
pour être
notre représentant
pour qu'on puisse
s'éplendre
du fait
qu'il a été
notre représentant
donc Adam
en tant que
représentant
dans ses pactes
donc ensuite
la Bible
vers les versets
jusqu'au verset 25
du chapitre 2
va conclure
cette section
qui décrit
l'état de félicité
et béatitude originale
je vous rappelle
Dieu qui dit
il n'est pas bon
que l'homme soit seul
et donc c'est la description
de quelle manière
Dieu a déjà
déclaré
Dieu lui-même
pour qu'il reste
aucun doute
que la femme
a été toujours
le projet de Dieu
pour complémenter
l'objectif
que l'humanité
soit à l'image
de Dieu
donc homme et femme
portent quelque chose
de l'image de Dieu
mais surtout
par les mariages
ils sont encore plus capables
de communiquer
l'image de Dieu
unité dans la diversité
tout comme la centrinité
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que même si Dieu
détermine et déclare
qu'il n'est pas bon
que l'homme soit seul
il permet
que l'homme lui-même
arrive à cette conclusion
l'homme parfait
qui va
interagir
avec la création
pour accomplir son rôle
et qui va conclure
qu'il n'a pas d'aide
semblable à lui
et il va
consommer
ou va conclure
en fait
une fois que Dieu
va créer la femme
avec ses poèmes
je l'appellerais
femme
Isha
car elle a été prise
de l'homme
donc l'égalité de valeur
des facultés
des noblesse
même si
Isha et Isha
sont des sexes
complémentaires
avec des rôles différents
selon les critères bibliques
et là
quand on arrive
au verset 25
on est devant
une nuance
très intéressante
pour faire la transition
vers la chute
l'homme
et la femme
ou l'homme
et sa femme
étaient tous deux
nus
et il en avait
point honte
donc qu'est-ce que cela représente ?
C'est un saut visible
d'innocence
car si aujourd'hui
dans notre compréhension
corrompue
la nudité
représente plutôt pour nous
de la honte
on sait très bien
comment nos appétits
tordus
charnels
peuvent être
enflammés
par ça
et voilà
tous les péchés
d'immoralité sexuelle
qui font que
on soit
très critérieux
pour nous protéger
ces choses
et pour tâcher
de manière très vite aussi
ceux qui
déviant
les plus vulgaires
ou nus
comme les manifestations
les plus
explicites
d'une espèce
d'abomination
quelque part
ça
pour plus
qu'on essaye
de renverser
ces principes
dans notre société
aujourd'hui
c'est tout simplement
quelque chose
qui marque
l'histoire
c'est un péché
qui fait
beaucoup tomber
mais en même temps
c'est quelque chose
qui est dans la société
on évite
et on considère
encore comme vulgaire
en même temps
selon
la compréhension
de cette
on va dire
corruption
au niveau sexuel
surtout dans
l'interaction
entre l'homme
et la femme
quand on
imagine
un extrême opposé
ça serait
de voir
que les deux
étaient nus
et qu'ils n'avaient
aucune honte
donc c'est la manière
humaine de dire
ils étaient tellement
bien équilibrés
il n'y avait pas
de problème
qu'ils soient nus
l'un devant l'autre
les appétites
physiologiques
étaient tellement
bien dosés
que la chose
se passait
exactement
de la manière
comme il faut
et donc
c'était un signe
d'innocence
et l'expression
ou les termes
c'était
ces termes
qui représentaient
nudité
et quand on arrive
au verset 1
ces mêmes termes
vont apparaître
mais avec une autre
connotation
l'opposé
quelque part
de l'innocence
les serpents
étaient les plus
dans l'original
les plus nus
de tous les animaux
créés par Dieu
donc ça
c'est un jeu
de mots
très important
inspiré
très riche
dans la parole
de Dieu
nous allons
bien comprendre
mais la première
chose à remarquer
c'est que
quand on arrive
à cet élément
on est devant
un élément
externe
de la tentation
les serpents
c'est très important
c'est un mystère
de découvrir
comment les péchés
rentrent dans le cœur
d'une femme parfaite
moralement parfaite
mais nous savons
au moins
que la Bible
est critérieuse
pour nous montrer
que la tentation
ou la séduction
vient
d'un élément
extérieur
les mâles
les péchés
et la tentation
sont
initiés
par une séduction
extérieure
Satan
a utilisé
ces serpents
pour conduire
à cette séduction
c'est clair
et c'est un mystère
pour nous
de comment
un désir
légitime
chez la femme
tout simplement
de manger
est devenu
un péché
et en général
ça se passe
comme ça
mais si la femme
était
coagie
au péché
elle n'aurait pas
une transgression
morale
la séduction
n'est pas
une imposition
la tentation
n'est pas
une imposition
si je suis tenté
cela n'est pas
une excuse
pour péché
à partir du moment
où je tombe
j'ai dû dire
oui
j'ai dû
participer
au péché
Jacques
chapitre 1
verset 13
à 15
nous dit
que personne
lorsqu'il est tenté
ne dise
c'est Dieu
qui me tente
car Dieu ne peut
être tenté
par le mal
et il ne tente
lui-même
personne
la Bible est très claire
avant qu'on commence
à mettre en question
cette permission divine
nous devons
refuser
des idées
que ce soit
quelque chose
inné
dans les corps
dans la constitution
humaine
dans la chair
de l'homme
cette dichotomie
qui a été aussi
favorisée par l'église catholique
au long de l'histoire
comme si
les corps
étaient mauvais
comme si c'était
les corps
qui conduit
quelque chose
au péché
à l'origine
c'est quelque chose
qui vient de l'extérieur
la deuxième chose
qu'il faut
considérer ici
c'est la manière
dont les péchés
a progressé
donc la Bible
elle nous dit
qu'un péché
est déjà un péché
quand il est encore
dans sa genèse
embryonnaire
dans notre cœur
mais surtout
dans un pacte
sur lequel
Dieu avait établi
une consommation
externe
objective
ses péchés
va arriver
jusqu'à sa consommation
et Jacques
dans les mêmes passages
il va continuer
à décrire les péchés
donc c'est pas
Dieu qui
Dieu n'est pas tenté
par les mâles
il n'est tente personne
mais chacun
est tenté
quand il est attiré
et amorcé
par sa propre
convoitise
puis la convoitise
parce qu'elle est conçue
enfante les péchés
et les péchés
étant consommés
produit la mort
et on voit clairement
comment Jacques
était en train
de se rapporter
à la description
et plus probablement
de ce qui se passe
en Genèse
elle est tentée
sa convoitise
interne
veut dire
oui
elle va consommer
à l'externe
et le résultat
sera la mort
et ces catégories
sont très importantes
pour nous
pour comprendre
tous les péchés
qu'on commet
et combien vite
on doit résister
mais c'est intéressant
de revenir
à ces sagesses
du langage biblique
l'homme et la femme
étaient les deux nus
et ils n'avaient point honte
et les versets
suivants
les serpents
étaient les plus rusés
ou les plus nus
de tous les animaux
des champs
que l'éternel de Dieu
avait fait
première chose
à remarquer
les serpents
étaient les plus nus
ça peut être pris
de manière littérale
dans le sens
où il est évoqué ici
comme
de tous les animaux
des champs
que l'éternel
Dieu avait fait
c'est à dire
c'est une référence
qui nous renvoie
aux serpents
avant la chute
et c'est intéressant
car il y a eu
une intentionnalité
de Satan
à faire un usage
particulier
de cet animal
un animal
qui peut être
fascinant
c'est difficile
pour nous
d'imaginer
mais même
pour Jean
il va dire ça
c'est une créature
qui ne pouvait pas
offrir
aucun mal
à l'origine
créée par Dieu
et fascinante
on sait très bien
que ça fait partie
de la chute
qu'une imitié
soit imposée
entre les serpents
et la race humaine
pour toujours
et il y a eu
un impact aussi
même sur son aspect
physique
on ne sait pas
si elle avait
des ailes
ou des pattes
mais nous savons
qu'indépendamment
du changement
qu'elle a eu
comme il y a eu
des changements
en nous
elle n'a pas perdu
non plus
toutes ses caractéristiques
et quand on regarde
tout simplement
littéralement
un serpent
on voit combien
c'est un animal
nu
il représente
la nudité
il n'y a pas
des poils
pour couvrir
et c'est un animal
quelque part
fascinant
ça peut montrer
déjà la subtilité
de Satan
en utilisant
un animal
qui pouvait
ne pas représenter
pour elle
en soi-même
aucune menace
et qui soit
peut-être
très intéressant
donc c'était
l'animal
le plus
nu
et c'est clair
que lorsque
Moïse est en train
d'écrire
il prend en considération
aussi notre compréhension
et l'usage
le plus fréquent du terme
et dans la signification
c'est rusé
tout simplement
et ça c'est la signification
primaire
donc c'est important
de remarquer
à l'origine
Ève
regardant
les serpents
en soi-même
n'a pas pu voir
directement
une menace
sauf que
comparativement
elle ne connaissait pas
personnellement
cet animal
elle connaissait
Dieu personnellement
son mari
personnellement
et pour plus
naïve
qu'elle
était
elle devrait
comparer
la parole
qu'elle avait
écoutée
de son mari
la parole
que son mari
avait écoutée
des dieux
elle devrait
lier les points
et dire
regarde la vie
que j'ai
sous la provision
des dieux
ma signification
ma relation
avec mon mari
toute cette prospérité
tout va très bien
je ne peux pas
trahir
la fidélité
de Dieu
qui m'a déjà
prouvé son amour
et la fidélité
de mon mari
avec
des paroles
séductrices
!
un inconnu
il faut aussi
reconnaître
de manière
très catégorique
que les diables
étaient en train
d'utiliser
ces serpents
la bible
elle le montre
partout
cette association
entre les diables
et les serpents
les dragons
l'ancien serpent
etc
la bible
nous montre aussi
parfois
comment les démons
peuvent même faire
posséder
des animaux
comme cette confrontation
entre Jésus
et les pourceaux
envers lesquels
ces démons
qui sont en train
d'interagir
vont vers les pourceaux
donc aucune chose
ne pourrait empêcher
cet être
personnel
spirituel
très puissant
de faire usage
d'un serpent
littéral
pour se communiquer
avec
Ève
dans cet épisode
donc il n'y a
aucun intérêt
pour nous
même car
les passages
lui-même
et là c'est
l'ironie
même les personnes
qui sont déjà
sous l'influence
de Satan
et qui veulent avoir
un abordage
non littéral
allégorique
mythologique
de cet épisode
ils doivent
au moins
prendre les leçons
et l'une des leçons
principales ici
c'est que
l'une des stratégies
les plus puissantes
de Satan
pour nous faire tomber
c'est de nous
conduire
à douter
de la parole
des dieux
douter des genèses
littérales
historiques
douter
que Satan
aurait pu utiliser
les serpents
pour parler
qui serait
les plus intéressés
et donc
il est présenté
Satan
comme les plus rusés
donc les plus rusés
ici c'est pas
tout simplement
les caractéristiques
du serpent
d'être nu
et les caractéristiques
du serpent
après la chute
qui devient
pour nous
les symboles
d'un animal
très dissimulé
subtil
qui vient
nous surprendre
et c'est bien sûr
la description
partout dans la Bible
à propos de Satan
son caractère
et ses stratégies
la subtilité
de s'aimer
les doutes
est la caractéristique
du premier
attaque
de Satan
les serpents
les plus rusés
de tous les animaux
des chants
que l'éternel
avait fait
il dit à la femme
Dieu
a-t-il
réellement
dit
vous ne mangerez pas
de tous les arbres
du jardin
qu'est-ce qui change
ici par rapport
à l'ordre
que Dieu avait donné
quelle est la
subtilité
du changement
si vous confrontez
les textes
qu'on a lus
au chapitre 2
lorsque Dieu
a donné les pactes
avec cette phrase
de Satan
qu'est-ce qui change
la question
qu'il pose
il dit à la femme
Dieu a-t-il
réellement dit
vous ne mangerez pas
de tous les arbres
du jardin
quelle est la différence
remarquez bien
Satan
il aime beaucoup
jouer avec la parole
des dieux
voilà pourquoi
il ne suffit pas
d'utiliser la Bible
d'ouvrir la Bible
car Satan
son stratégie
c'est de jouer
avec la parole
des dieux
il prend
la parole des dieux
et il est en train
de tordre la parole
des dieux
qu'est-ce qui change
personne ne veut oser
comparer les textes
hein
vous ne mangerez pas
de tous les arbres
la déclaration
est véritable
Dieu
à la fin des comptes
ce que Dieu
avait communiqué
remarquez bien
la subtilité
pourrait signifier
l'effet
qu'eux
ils ne peuvent pas
manger
de tous les arbres
car il y a
un arbre
qui ne peut pas
manger
rien
qui est la manière
de formuler
les questions
et voilà pourquoi
je suis
à date
de la
l'apologétique
présuppositionnaliste
dans quel sens
on n'est jamais
en train
de répondre
tout simplement
à la question
en soi
que les personnes
sont en train de poser
je ne dirais pas
jamais
mais
en général
derrière
les questions
il y a
d'autres questions
possiblement
des intentions
et nous
devons être
sensibles
à chercher
à identifier
l'intentionnalité
derrière cette question
et donc
dans cette question
il dit
à la femme
Dieu a-t-il
réellement dit
vous ne
mangerez pas
de tous les arbres
du jardin
donc qu'est-ce que
Dieu avait dit
réellement
donc Dieu a dit
!
tu pourras manger
de tous les arbres
du jardin
mais tu ne mangeras pas
de l'arbre
de la connaissance
du bien du mal
c'est
tout
moins un
en mettant
toute l'emphase
sur les tous
vous êtes avec moi?
en mettant
toute l'emphase
sur le fait
qu'il y a un Dieu généreux
qui veut juste
enlever quelque chose
qui ne vous manque pas
pour vous donner
l'opportunité
de vous élever
davantage
et rendre
votre condition
de béatitude éternelle
il n'y a qu'il y a
de la grâce
et qu'il vous donne
un ordre sévère
pour vous protéger
afin que vous
ne mangez pas
comment Satan
commence à faire
d'abord il commence
pour s'aimer
les doutes
a-t-il réellement
dit?
est-ce que tu l'as
écouté directement
des dieux?
ou est-ce que c'était
plutôt ton mari
qui l'a écouté?
si c'est ton mari
qui l'a écouté
est-ce que tu fais
vraiment confiance
à ton mari?
et en plus
de s'aimer
les doutes
envers les maris
Satan
va s'aimer
les doutes
envers Dieu
car c'est déjà
la sémence
d'une mise
en question
de l'intentionnalité
de Dieu
ou du caractère
car au lieu
de voir Dieu
comme un Dieu
généreux
un père
c'est une tendance
à regarder Dieu
comme un Dieu
restrictif
c'est cette mentalité
les dix commandements
sont là pour promouvoir
la vie
la plénitude
de la vie
et nous voyons
les dix commandements
comme si c'était
aujourd'hui on dit
une camisole de force
il n'y a rien
qui puisse
faire plus prospérer
la réalité
des êtres humains
donc ici on voit
de manière
très intéressante
un Dieu
infiniment généreux
et on voit
cette manière
de Satan
détordre
si on va bien
au verset 9
du chapitre 2
il dit encore
Dieu a pu pousser
du sol
des arbres
de toute espèce
agréable à voir
et bon à manger
et l'arbre de la vie
au milieu du jardin
c'est à dire
même
entre guillemets
une sainte tentation
qui devrait
surmonter
l'autre tentation
la sainte tentation
de nous cibler
plus vers l'arbre
de la vie
s'il y a
deux arbres
que je ne peux pas
manger aujourd'hui
envers lesquels
je vais développer
plus mes aspirations
connaissance
du bien
et du mal
autonomie
déterminer
moi-même
déterminer moi-même
c'est qu'elle est mieux
pour moi
ou me focaliser
sur cette grande récompense
qui est Dieu
et tous les péchés
c'est la même histoire
obéissance
qui mène à la vie
discipline
qui est
même si parfois
c'est les chemins plus longs
c'est les raccourcis
les plus courts
pour être béni
et des raccourcis
qu'on prend
pour satisfaire
nos volontés immédiates
deviennent pour nous
à long terme
beaucoup plus
des dégâts
et des rétardements
dans notre propre
prospérité
et donc
il va tordre
subtilement
ensuite
dans la prochaine
interaction
et là déjà
on voit
comment la femme
a cédé
car quelle était
la réponse
de la femme
qu'est-ce qu'on voit
dans la réponse
de la femme
la femme
répondit au serpent
nous mangeons
du fruit
des arbres
du jardin
elle commence
à manquer
déjà
des générosités
dans sa description
très générale
mais quant au fruit
de l'arbre
qu'il y a
au milieu
du jardin
Dieu a dit
jusque là
ça semble bien
c'est Dieu
qui a dit
réellement
donc elle fait
confiance à son mari
c'est Dieu
qui l'a dit
vous n'en mangerez
point
et vous
n'y toucherez
point
des peurs
que vous
ne mouriez
qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait
ici
elle a rajouté
et elle a enlevé
aussi
il faut faire
beaucoup d'attention
qu'est-ce qu'elle a rajouté
n'est touché point
quelle est la réussite
de Satan ici
une perspective
restrictive
des dieux
au lieu de voir
un dieu des grâces
généreux
un père qui me protège
et qui veut me récompenser
je commence à voir
un dieu
qui est restrictif
un dieu d'interdition
ce n'est pas les promoteurs
de la vie
c'est celui
qui est là
pour interdire
et n'y toucher
point
il faut qu'on apprenne
la méthodologie
légaliste
va dans sa direction
et selon l'apôtre Paul
elle n'est fait
qu'est
provoquer davantage
la tentation
la mentalité
d'un dieu
d'interdition
et quel est
l'ajout
qu'elle a fait
non pardon
qu'est-ce qu'elle a réduit
là
des peurs
dans le sens
où
Dieu avait dit
certainement
vous mourrez
et maintenant
des peurs
il y a une possibilité
il y a une menace
on ne sait pas
si ça va vraiment
se passer
comme dit
JC Rye
l'enfer
est la vérité
reconnue
trop tard
quand on veut jouer
avec la notion
de l'enfer
en nous disant
on n'est pas encore là
on va découvrir
après
mais c'est tout simplement
une vérité
une réalité
que tous
vont devoir reconnaître
mes serpents
vont les faire
trop tard
donc elle est déjà
en train de céder
ensuite
une nouvelle attaque
c'est quatre
alors les serpents
disent à la femme
vous n'aimourez point
donc à partir de là
c'est une contradiction
ouverte à la parole
c'est comme dans une lutte
il a testé
combien un garde
était la femme
était son homme
dans l'omission complète
jusque là
lui qui avait été appelé
par Dieu
pour être
les gardiens
du jardin
de la femme
les gardiens
du jardin
c'est lui
qui devrait être
celui qui servirait
avec les leadership
pour les développements
et pour la protection
et c'est lui
qui est
complètement
en omission
dans tous ces échanges
et donc ici
on voit
les serpents
disent à la femme
vous n'aimourez
point
et on se rappelle
très bien
l'ordre
qui avait été donné
à l'homme
au chapitre 2
verset 16
l'éternel
donna cet ordre
à l'homme
tu pourras manger
de tous les arbres
du jardin
mais tu ne mangeras
pas de l'arbre
de la connaissance
du bien et du mal
car les jours
où tu en mangeras
tu mourras
c'est que Dieu
a dit réellement
car les jours
où tu en mangeras
tu mourras
certainement
en mourant
tu mourras
ok
et donc
c'est que la femme
a cédé
des peurs
elle a baissé
la garde
et donc Satan
a vu
l'opportunité
de maximiser
voilà pourquoi
dans le proverbe
on va voir
cet appel
à fuir
de l'apparence
du mal
même les chemins
qui mènent
à la maison
de l'adultère
c'est même pas
ne pas croiser
sa maison
c'est de ne même pas
passer par les chemins
qui pourraient
amener
à sa maison
fuir
de la moindre
apparence du mal
car
la moindre garde
baissée
Satan
va grandir
et donc
une confrontation
directe
à la parole
des dieux
donc ça commence
avec
un usage
manipulateur
de la parole
des dieux
dissimulé
subtil
et ça commence
à grandir
ça commence
et les hérésies
c'est de la même sorte
et donc ensuite
on voit à nouveau
une autre
progression
dans l'attaque
verset 5
mais Dieu sait
regardez
il commence
à mettre
des paroles
dans la pensée
des dieux
et il commence
à devenir
une source
non inspirée
indirecte
des révélations
à propos des dieux
il veut donner
des informations
à propos des dieux
sauf qu'il n'a
aucune autorisation
pour les faire
mais Dieu sait
!
que les jours
où vous en mangerez
vos yeux
s'ouvriront
et que vous serez
comme des dieux
connaissant les biens
et les mal
et donc c'est cette
tentation
qui va dans la direction
ou dans la même
direction
que la chute
de Satan
lui-même
d'être
égal
à Dieu
il y a
une influence
très présente
dans nos cultures
aujourd'hui
et c'est
un peu ironique
car on dit
vivre dans une génération
relativiste
qui ne croit pas
dans les religions
mais qui
en même temps
embrasse
quelques courants
les moins rationnels
en termes
des religions
donc l'ésotérisme
par exemple
et cette idée
en fait
qu'on est
comme
quelque part
une partie
de cet univers
et avec la mentalisation
ou la pensée positive
on peut faire
les choses
c'est passé
et donc
c'est cette notion
comme si
on avait
quand même
un peu
des dieux
et par cette
mentalisation
et même
les églises évangéliques
parfois
vont
emporter
cette hérésie
et couvrir
avec un vernis
d'évangélisme
mais c'est cette notion
comme si
on était
des petits dieux
qui est toujours
en train
de déclarer
de déterminer
d'obliger Dieu
à répondre
à nos prières
selon nos termes
mettre Dieu
contre les murs
d'écrire
dans un cahier
les choses
qu'on aurait aimées
etc.
Dieu devient
un espenseur
domestiqué
pour nos idolâtries
personnelles
et donc
il dit
Satan
vous serez
comme Dieu
Dieu sait
en fait
c'est un Dieu
jaloux
tyran
c'est un Dieu
qui veut
enlever
votre dignité
qui ne veut pas
permettre
que vous-même
décidez
ce qu'il y a
bien ou mauvais
pour vos vies
vos yeux
s'ouvriront
et vous serez
comme des dieux
connaissant les biens
et les mal
le seul sens
dans lequel Dieu
connaît les biens
et les mal
c'est par la perspective
de son trône
des juges
Dieu
ne souffre pas
les mal
lui-même
si ce n'est qu'il
de manière
rédemptrice
volontairement
en Jésus Christ
pour nous sauver
et même là
les plaisirs
que Dieu
prend
sur la rédemption
surmontent
ces mal
qu'il subit
volontairement
mais ce qui est intéressant
à remarquer ici
c'est une contradiction
ouverte
contre la parole
des dieux
avec l'insertion
de la plus radicale
des tentations
être comme Dieu
et déterminer
ce qu'il y a
bien ou mauvais
et donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe
à partir de là
jusqu'ici
c'est les doutes
contre la parole
des dieux
les soupçons
contre la bonté
des dieux
et la tentation
pour être
Dieu
au lieu des dieux
donc verset 6
la femme vit
qu'à l'arbre
était bon à manger
était
agréable
à la vue
et qu'il était
précieux
pour ouvrir
l'intelligence
donc
les puritans
les réformés
remarquent
que déjà
dans les processus
de la chute
tous les dix commandements
sont franchis
donc on voit
comment presque
toutes les œuvres
de la chair
se manifestent
nous sommes devant
les mensonges
les faux témoignages
à propos de dieux
l'idolâtrie
la trahison
dans les relations
entre la fidélité
qui est la forme
des vrais voies
envers l'homme
l'homme
qui n'est plus
un père
ou un homme
honorable
la famille
renversée
les pères
qui ne protègent pas
la femme
qui prend la direction
qui offre
les fruits
à l'homme
et
dans toute l'histoire
de l'humanité
ce qui a conduit
à la chute
c'était
de renverser
l'image des dieux
dans l'homme
et la femme
et dans leurs
relations familiales
la punition
comme on verra
dans la prochaine fois
elle va
se porter aussi
sur cette bataille
qui va marquer
la race humaine
jusqu'à la fin
la bataille
entre les sexes
ton désir
sera pour ton mari
c'est-à-dire
tu vas désirer
occuper sa position
mais lui
en réponse
au lieu de
conduire
bibliquement
la famille
il va te dominer
et les pages
de l'histoire
sont marquées
soit
par
un féminisme
extrême
comme réaction
à des générations
et générations
d'abus masculins
envers les femmes
on ne revient pas
à l'équilibre
biblique
on va bouger
entre ces deux
extrêmes
et voilà pourquoi
l'autoconnaissance
elle est très importante
à cet égard
car je dois
reconnaître
que comme conséquence
de la chute
ça fait partie
d'une bataille
constante dans ma vie
en tant qu'homme
soit d'être
omis
abusif
en tant qu'homme
au lieu
d'exercer
un leadership
chrétien
et chez ma femme
soit
elle sera tentée
être manipulatrice
soit
elle va désirer
occuper
ma position
à la maison
à la société
ou n'importe où
et tout cela
commence
car la chute
elle-même
était marquée
par la désordre
à cet égard
et donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe
ici
les aspects
les plus charnels
prends l'élan ici
la partie
la moins noble
de l'être
dans la poussière
qui est attirée
par la faim
ou au moins
les désirs
de manger
la tentation
quand la faim
n'est pas là
et pour plus bête
que ça puisse paraître
les pires péchés
au long de l'histoire
d'Israël
passent par la question
de la nourriture
la tentation
et les manques
de maîtrise
donc l'arbre
était bon à manger
agréable à la vue
et qu'il était précieux
pour ouvrir
l'intelligence
donc des tentations
envers l'âme
des tentations
envers les corps
cet orgueil
c'est qui va être décrit
par Jean
dans sa lettre
au deuxième chapitre
car tout ce qui est
dans les mondes
la convoitise
de la chair
c'est-à-dire
ses désirs
corporels
ou sensuels
non conformes à Dieu
la convoitise
des yeux
c'est qui est
tout simplement
agréable
à la vue
et l'orgueil
de la vie
ça prend attention
cette vanité
de vouloir être
comme Dieu
de déterminer les règles
pour ouvrir l'intelligence
ici dans les passages
et donc ici
ils sont en train
de consommer
les péchés
et donc par cette
consommation
de péchés
nous arrivons
verset 7
pour conclure aujourd'hui
où nous lisons
les yeux
des l'un
et des l'autre
s'ouvrirent
ils connurent
qu'ils étaient
nus
et ayant cousu
des feuilles
des figuilles
ils s'enfirent
des ceintures
remarquez bien
les thèmes
de la nudité
l'espoir
de l'évangile
bientôt
vers la fin
du passage
on verra ça
la prochaine fois
nous montre
que l'homme
n'arrive jamais
à se couvrir
de ses fautes
à cacher
sa coupabilité
sa honte
l'abomination
qui nous sommes
envers nous-mêmes
car nous savons
que nous sommes
en abomination
pour Dieu
à cause
de nos fautes
on est conscient
de cette distorsion
de cette corruption
de notre innocence
et on essaye
de se cacher
voilà pourquoi
quand on a la honte
on met les mains
sur les visages
mais la manière
et les efforts du monde
pour se couvrir
ne sont jamais suffisants
qu'est-ce que Dieu
va faire
et à la fin du passage
c'est Dieu lui-même
qui va prendre
les peaux
des animaux
pour les couvrir
et les peaux
de ces animaux
représentent
les saints versés
substitutifs
les animaux
ont dû mourir
à leur place
verser leur sang
pour que la juste colère
de Dieu soit apaisée
pour un instant
jusqu'à ce que Dieu
puisse pourvoir
les vrais
agneaux pascales
les Christ
qui viendraient
afin que Christ
lui-même
qui à la croix
a été aussi
dénué
avec ses vêtements
déchirés
qui s'est exposé
à cette humiliation
il a pris sur lui
notre nudité
pécheresse
afin de nous couvrir
avec sa santé
parfaite
et voilà
de quelle manière
théologiquement
bibliquement
historiquement
Genèse 3
la chute
est absolument nécessaire
historiquement
et littéralement
pour qu'on comprenne
l'évangile
et pour qu'on réjouisse
de l'évangile
et pour qu'on comprenne
pour qu'on comprenne
!